In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Srinaksadion for June 24, on which we commemorate the Nativity
of the Holy and Glorious Prophet, Forerunner and Baptist, John.
On the 24th of the month we celebrate the Nativity of the venerable and Glorious Prophet
and Forerunner, John the Baptist.
As soon as the Archangel Gabriel had left the most holy Mother of God, after having announced
the good news of her virginal childbearing and having referred to her cousin Elizabeth's
pregnancy as a confirmation of his words, Mary went with haste to the village in Judea
where Zachariah and Elizabeth lived.
She greeted her cousin and immediately the six-month fetus in Elizabeth's womb leapt
for joy, making himself the Savior's Forerunner even before his birth.
Elizabeth lent her own voice to the Prophet and cried aloud, Blessed are Thou among women,
and Blessed is the fruit of thy womb.
And once is this to me, that the Mother of my Lord should come to me.
Mary replied with her wondrous canticle of thanksgiving, My soul doth magnify the Lord.
She remained with Elizabeth for three months, giving her practical help, and talking with
her about God's wonderful acts.
Then, she returned home.
When the time arrived or Elizabeth to give birth, she brought a son into the world who was
welcomed with joy and gladness by his family and all the neighbors.
On the eighth day, when they circumcised the child, they wished to name him after Zachariah
his father, as was the custom.
But Elizabeth spoke up and said quite categorically, Not so.
He shall be called John.
Those who were present objected that no one in their family had ever been called John,
and turning to Zachariah, they asked for his opinion, for he had remained deaf and dumb
since the time that the Archangel Gabriel had visited him.
Zachariah asked for a writing tablet and wrote, His name is John.
At that very moment, he was delivered from his dumbness and filled with a Holy Spirit,
and began to prophesy and to address this hymn to God.
Blessed be the Lord, the God of Israel, for he has visited and redeemed his people, and
hath raised up a mighty Savior for us in the house of his servant David, as he promised
by the mouths of his holy prophets, who have been since the world began.
And thou, child, thou shalt be called the prophet of the most high, for thou shalt go before
the face of the Lord to prepare his ways to give knowledge of salvation to his people by
the forgiveness of their sins.
He who was born contrary to all expectation from a barren womb, brought forth a spiritual
springtime by his birth, proclaiming that the Messiah, whose way he was preparing, would
come to renew the laws of human nature and to open to humankind the path to deification.
He who was called by God to become the voice of the Word, freed his Father's tongue, which
had been made captive by his lack of faith, and put an end to the figures and shadows of
the Old Covenant.
The last of the prophets, John, according to the words of the Lord, is the greatest of all
those born of woman, and is also the first of the apostles.
Being born on that day, he began to shine in the world as the flaming torch of the true
light, as the star proclaiming the sun of righteousness, and as the herald announcing the appearing
of the Word, fear and wonder took hold of all who were present, and the news spread throughout
the whole of Judea.
The child grew and his spirit became strong, for the hand of the Lord was upon him.
As soon as he was weaned and able to walk, he left the family home, and went to live in
the desert, where dressed in camel skin and wearing a leather belt around his loins,
he fed on locusts and wild honey.
This man of whom the world was unworthy lived there a life without anxiety or sadness, delivered
from the passions and assaults of desire, contemplating God in his heart, and making him his delight
and consolation.
Other prophets before him had certainly lived in the desert, for example Moses and Elias,
but John, living in the desert as if in heaven, was superior to these, and manifested by his
retreat the renewal of human nature, of which he had been made the forerunner, and inaugurated
for humankind the possibility of living like angels while in the flesh.
Overginity, Askeesys, and contemplation.
He led this angelic life in the desert until the fifteenth year of the reign of Tiberius
Caesar, when the word of God came to him, ordering him to return to the inhabited parts of
the region, in order to proclaim the coming of the Lord to prepare his ways, by exhorting
the people to repent and be baptized in the Jordan for the remission of their sins.
As all were asking themselves if John might be the Messiah for whom Israel was waiting, he
answered them, saying, I indeed baptize you with water, but one mightier than I comeeth.
The latchet of whose shoes I am not worthy to unloose.
He shall baptize you with the Holy Spirit and with fire.
With many others such exhortations, he proclaimed to the people the good news of salvation in
Christ Jesus our Lord.
Although all the prophecies of St. John the Baptist have found their fulfillment, his message
remains of permanent value for the church.
He will not cease to be the forerunner until the end of time, proclaiming to all who wish
to welcome the Savior, that is by repentance, the cutting off of worldly pleasures, retreat
and prayer, that they may prepare in themselves the way by which Christ will make his entry
in the power of the Holy Spirit.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.